[Musik]
religion und sexualität das klingt nach
einer schwierigen beziehung religion und
weibliche sexualität bedeuten vollends
die alarmglocken
herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion der film female pressure der
gerade in den deutschschweizer kinos
läuft erzählt die geschichten von fünf
frauen aus verschiedenen kulturen die in
ihren jeweiligen gesellschaften gegen
sexuellen missbrauch gegen
diskriminierung und für mehr
selbstbestimmung kämpfen
die kirche war meine heimat und jetzt
ist die kirche für mich die räuberhöhle
von der jesus im evangelium spricht ein
ort von dem man sich besser fern sind
[Musik]
da zwei babys haben craig ob also got
talent der instinkt bin grundsätzlich
haares
any public space
bad iburg hate myself 131 trend
eingestellt
[Musik]
bei mir im studio begrüße ich nun die
regisseurin des films barbara müller
herzlich willkommen
religionswissenschaftlerin anna
katharina höpflinger und doris wagner
sie ist eine der fünf protagonisten im
film
ihnen allen herzlich ist willkommen
bartram ina der film ist gerade
angelaufen aber schon seit wochen in
aller munde was sind denn die häufigsten
reaktionen
also für mich war es sehr überwältigend
zu sehen dass er sehr gut aufgenommen
wird von frauen von männern auch aber
auch aus religiösen kreisen also dass
sehr viel unterstützung kommt vor allem
von der basis wir haben einen preis
gewonnen
dok festival deutschland von der
interreligiösen jury wurden wir speziell
ausgezeichnetes habe mich auch sehr
gefreut gar keine negativen reaktionen
bisher bis jetzt eigentlich nicht dass
es ist ganz erstaunlich war nicht haben
mich erinnern als wir an der welt
premiere waren wir waren alles so
angespannt und es gab zehn minuten
standing ovation und das war wirklich
sowie eine große erlösung auch frau
klinger es fällt auf dass das thema
religion sexualität im moment sehr
präsent ist es spenden kirchliche
tagungen dazu es finden akademische
thementage dazu es finden dazu warum ist
das thema gerade jetzt derartige und ich
würde sagen dass war immer virulent aber
das wichtige ist dass jetzt die welt
verändert sich und man baut sich auch
wirklich in der
die zeit darüber zu reden es hat also
eine veränderung gegeben dass es ein
thema wird das plötzlich sehr stark
öffentlich debattiert werden
also müssen sich religion irgendwie auch
dazu positionieren
denken sie die ganze debatte hat einen
einfluss darauf gehabt sicher auch ja
die mit da wird was ich ja auch wichtig
vor allem bezüglich weibliche sexualität
und religion wenn das vorher oft einfach
er generell um religion ging oder um
normierung von sexualität oder auch um
männliche sexualität doris wagner sie
haben theologie und philosophie studiert
sie haben gerade ihre dissertation
eingereicht und sie sind haben es gerade
gesehen eine der frauen empfehlen auf
ihre geschichte als ehemalige ordensfrau
werden wir gleich noch ausführlicher zu
sprechen kommen zunächst aber einmal die
frage wie ist es für sie jetzt mit
diesem thema und als person derart in
der öffentlichkeit zu stehen
ja das ist ambivalent auf der einen
seite ist das ganz merkwürdig für mich
natürlich mit meinem hintergrund jahre
lang im verborgenen irgendwo in küchen
gemüse geputzt zu haben und jetzt auf
einmal hier im studio sitzen und auf
bühnen zu stehen ist ein sehr komisches
gefühl und ich ich brauche das für mich
nicht ich bin ganz froh wenn ich nachher
wieder zu hause bei mir bin und in der
küche stehen für maschinen aus räume
oder am schreibtisch sitze auf der
anderen seite ist das für mich eine
wunderbare gelegenheit und sagen zu
können ich stehe hier für viele andere
frauen die was ähnliches erlebt haben
und wie sie gesagt hatten wir reden
jetzt endlich darüber und ich erzähle
nicht nur meine geschichte erzählt durch
meine geschichte die geschichten von so
vielen frauen und ich habe eine bühne
jetzt ich habe eine öffentlichkeit die
mir zuhört und dass es wenn ein
wunderbarer effekt von diesem film
wir kommen noch mal kurz auf den film
und die anlage des films zu sprechen wir
haben diese organisation in indien wo
sich eine gruppe junger leute stark
macht um über das thema in der
öffentlichkeit zu sprechen wir haben die
künstlerin aus japan die vagina kunst
herstellt wir haben das engagement von
leila hussein gegen die weibliche
genitalverstümmelung wir haben den
ausbruch von der ba fällt man aus ihrem
ultra-orthodoxen jüdischen milieu und
eben ihre geschichte als ehemalige
ordensfrau das sind ja doch sehr
unterschiedliche geschichten ganz
unterschiedlichen gesellt
schafften haben wir wirklich etwas
gemeinsam also für mich das war ja
eigentlich wirklich die grundlage ich
wollte erforschen wie es den frauen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert geht hab
dann wie die fünf weltreligionen und
wirklich einen globalen blick zu
bekommen als grundlage genommen und das
erstaunliche ist dass es uns eigentlich
auf der ganzen welt sehr ähnlich geht
also dieser blick auf die frau als
weniger wert auf aus der weibliche
körper der die sünde gebracht hat das
zieht sich durch alle religionen
gesellschaften kulturen und von dem er
ja also das war auch wird man sich die
frauen das erste mal getroffen habe war
wirklich so ein gegenseitiges
verständnis und wir haben euch die
gleiche sprache und von den gleichen
dingen gesprochen
frau wagner haben sie sich in den
geschichten der anderen protagonistinnen
auch wieder gefunden ja absolut und das
war auch für mich in dem moment wie
barbara kam und und wir von dem konzept
des films erzählt hat auch und ich weiß
von den anderen frauen für die war das
auch der moment wo wir gesagt haben ja
genau das wollen wir
wir wollen nicht nur für unsere kultur
sprechen wir wollen diese diese
parallelität selber auch sichtbar machen
um zu verhindern dass man immer mit dem
finger auf andere kulturen zeigen kann
und sein kann hertha passiert das oder
in anfangen muss seine eigene kultur zu
verteidigen oder zu bekämpfen sondern
das tiefer liegende probleme sichtbar zu
machen dass es darum geht wie kulturen
und religionen benutzt werden um frauen
abzuwerten und ihnen gewalt anzutun das
ist das thema das uns alle beschäftigt
das nicht so sehr die religion oder die
kultur
wir haben das filmplakat hierbei und wie
sehen es gibt da nebst der hand die sich
in die höhe reckt auch die symbole der
einzelnen religionen frau höpflinger wie
stark sehen sie denn die frage der
weiblichen diskriminierung aufgrund der
sexualität wirklich als ein thema in den
religionen
wir diskutieren hier jetzt auch über
religion und kultur vielleicht zunächst
mal wo ist da der unterschied zwischen
religion und kultur wo entlang geht die
grenze das ist eine frage ich glaube
wenn ich die büste der reichtum nun
endlich berühmt aber ich betrachte
religion als unterkategorie vom kultur
aber selbstverständlich gibt es auch
andere positionen die sagen religion ist
das wichtige eine kultur ist eine
unterkategorie von religion also eben
diese differenz linie ziehen ist
schwierig und muss je nach religion
einzeln gezogen werden jetzt ich denke
zur frage sexualität und religion
ich denke sexualität ist ein
existenzielles grundbedürfnis des
menschen und oder vielleicht eher eine
existenzielle grundfrage man natürlich
gibt es menschen die ihnen keine
sexuellen bedürfnisse haben also auch
sexuelle menschen und jetzt religionen
beschäftigen sich mit existenziellen
grundfragen des menschen insofern finde
ich ist sexualität eines der wichtigen
themen von sagen wir wirklich doch sagen
global fast allen religionen also
religion beschäftigen sich de facto mit
sexualität
insofern natürlich auch mit weiblicher
sexualität jetzt aber wie einzelne
religionen sich mit weiblicher
sexualität beschäftigen dass es dann
religions- spezifisch also es gibt auch
so genannte materie lineare religionen
also wo doch die frau eher ins zentrum
steht aus der man also beispielsweise im
judentum wo weil die weitergabe der
religion über die mutter verläuft oder
haben sie noch etwas anderes im
hinterkopf
also ich werde das judentum doch eher
als patriarchale religion bezeichnen im
sinn von dass der im fokus hat man
ausgerichtet ist aber es gibt zum
beispiel in nordost indien eine kultur
der kasse dort wird das erbe also das
ganze auch der landbesitz wir frau vom
weitervererbt und die frau steht im
zentrum
auch eine andere kultur in die muss so
in china da gibt es tatsächlich nicht
unsere art von ehe ursprünglich sondern
eine art von besuchs beziehung mit dem
mann kommt zu der frau und sie bestimmt
dann auch stärker über die sexualität
das gibt auch aber natürlich es ist die
minderheit und in den großen
weltreligionen ist das doch so dass die
frau dann eher das nachsehen
sozusagen hat genau ich würde sagen die
großen weltreligionen fokussieren auf
den man auf idealen mensch woher kommt
das also wir haben wir diskutieren wenn
wir über religion und sexualität
sprechen haben natürlich sehr schnell
sozusagen die religiösen schriften die
sakralen schriften als die fundamente im
hinterkopf die dazu aussagen machen ist
das so
wagner stehen in der bibel wirklich so
prägnante aussagen die eindeutig zu
diesem befund kommen müssen dass die
männer über die frauen herrschen auch in
der frage des vorliegens das ist eine
schwierige frage ich würde sagen ja und
nein
und vielleicht sollte man zuerst mal die
frage stellen wie
religionsgemeinschaften mit ihren
sakralen schriften umgehen und wie sie
damit umgehen sollten
denn die die schriften sind natürlich
müssen gerade unserer zeit historisch
kritisch untersucht dann ausgelegt
werden
und wenn man das tut dann kommt man kann
schnell zu dem befund dass natürlich in
diesen schriften sich die die
wertvorstellungen derzeit finden in der
die schriften entstanden sind und das
ist für alle da die großen
religionsgemeinschaften ist das eine
über ordnung des mannes über die frau
und sind als andere gesellschaftliche
normen die für uns heute nicht mehr
gelten
und das fatale ist aber dass diese
schriften über jahrhunderte hinweg
anders ausgelegt worden seien und
wirkungsgeschichte entfaltet haben
die dazu geführt haben dass diese alten
wertvorstellungen von jahrtausende alten
kulturen und gesellschaften einfach der
stehzeit transportiert und gefestigt
worden sind bis in unsere zeit und ich
würde sagen für für unseren westlichen
kulturkreis sehr vom christentum geprägt
ist kann man sogar sagen dass auch leute
die sich heute als völlig säkular
begreifen
trotzdem mit diesem mit diesen bildern
und geschichten aufgewachsen sind und
das in sich aufgesogen haben jedes große
museum in dem das man geht findet man
biblische geschichten dargestellt und
die frauen haben da immer die rolle dass
sie entweder mütter sind oder
sünderinnen sind oder aber die frauen
sind nie die die vorne stehen und die
reden und die das wort gottes
verbindlich auslegen für die
gemeinschaft und die gemeinschaft führen
und auch leute die eben nicht damit
aufgewachsen sind dass sie das glauben
haben diese bilder verinnerlicht pamela
man könnte jetzt auch ganz kritisch
fragen sie haben empfehlen immer wieder
auch einzelne zitate aus sakralen
schriften der einzelnen religionen
genommen aber sind immer genau die die
sozusagen dieses bild
der mann steht über der frau zementieren
sie hätten aber auch die möglichkeit
gehabt die anderen stellen zu wählen
warum haben sie sich nicht dafür
entschieden weil das eigentlich meistens
nicht die art ist wie die religion
interpretiert wurden und gelebt werden
also mich hat interessiert
also man sieht ja wie die realität also
die frauen kämpfen darum akzeptiert zu
werden als wertvoll angeschaut werden
dass ihre sexualität eben nicht
verteufelt wird und dann habe ich mich
gefragt woher kommt das eigentlich und
habt dann in allen fünf heiligen
schriften solche grundlagen auch
gefunden aber trage sie nicht auch zur
zementierung jetzt dazu bei weil die
meisten menschen kennen ja diese zitat
oder diese textstellen die eben zu
dieser unterdrückung führen gingen ist
aber viel weniger bekannt dass es eben
auch alternativen gibt in den gleichen
schrift also das war schon auch eine
frage wollen wir im film auch weil die
fünf protagonisten die setzen sich ja
sehr mit der religion mit der kultur
auseinander aber ihre art damit
umzugehen auch wenn sie zum teil sehr
schwierige sachen erlebt haben ist sehr
positiv und dann war schon auch die
frage wollen wir diese positiven zitate
die es auch gibt auch in den filmen
neben es war dann wieso man hat ich habe
gemerkt 90 minuten passt nicht alles
rein aber im ja das wäre natürlich auch
die vielleicht müssen wir ein zweiter
film machen und sagen jetzt fokussieren
wir auch das positive das zum beispiel
auch in den heiligen schriften dasteht
über die starken frauenfiguren die
vergessen wurden über die über die ganze
zeit über die es im judentum und
christentum eigentlich irgendwie in
tourismus gibt es diese ganz starken
frauenfiguren aber die haben dann
überhaupt keine rolle mehr gespielt und
heute spricht man nicht mal mehr über
sie weiß wagner ihre bewegende
geschichte hat ihren ausgang nicht in
einer kultur fremden religion sondern
hier inmitten europas im system der
römisch katholischen kirche
wir schauen uns jetzt kurz ein paar
ausschnitte dann so an papst franziskus
ist eine figur die 401 hoffnung gegeben
hat dass ich in der kirche was ende
[Applaus]
ebenfalls ich habe einen brief an parts
franziskus geschrieben
[Applaus]
giovanni marchese mehdi karrubi teil
zehn jahre in richmond presse kultur
bietet mediola balkone wollten lacasa
die formationen den fc st romana wie
mobilität rovereto werke in 3d the dome
sap erp bohren um parameter ultima die
bibel es ganz lange benutzt worden
dieses bild der frau als gefahr der frau
als weniger wert der froh als sünderin
zu festigen und zu entwerfen
mir war klar dass ordensfrauen durch
alle jahrhunderte hinweg solche sachen
erlebt werden
aber das erleben dieser frauen war nie
relevant ordensfrau werden ins kloster
gehen das hatte gott schon immer für
mich vorbereiten
eine schwester kam zu mir aufs zimmer
mit zu einem langen unterkleid und sagte
das tragen wir für unsere mitglieder
mehr hat sie gar nicht gesagt habe ich
nicht verstanden ja okay das ist
irgendwie für die priester
wahrscheinlich schwierig wenn sie mit
frauen und selben haus zu sagen ihr
leben weil das sind der frau gefunden
und je weniger man sieht dass es frauen
sind es so leichter es ist für sie ich
habe angefangen mich zu schämen
es war nicht schwierig aber komisch die
ersten schritte in einen normalen leben
anzufangen
ich habe lange zeit ein schuldgefühl
dabei gehabt das erste mal mitspielen
können
ein sommerkleid und das erste mal großen
anzuziehen
[Musik]
er habe sie das bedürfnis gehabt meinen
körper zu spüren
[Musik]
und dann musik hören zu können richtige
musik die gefühle ausdrückt liebeslieder
das war wie wieder zum leben kommen im
buch nicht mehr ich erzählen sie ihre
geschichte ausführlich sie schreiben
dass sie aus einer sehr fromm familie
stammen die zunächst einmal evangelisch
lutherisch war dann zum katholizismus
übergetreten ist
sie haben mit 19 abitur gemacht und sind
dann in die ordensgemeinschaft das werk
eingetreten
nach acht jahren in denen sie
vergewaltigt manipuliert und entmündigt
wurden so schreiben sie sind sie dann
ausgetreten
woher kam überhaupt der wunschname zu
werten dass es schwierig ist es auch
nicht so schwierig für mich war das
einerseits weiß normales weil die
religion die welt war mit echt
aufgewachsen bin und andererseits war es
sicher auch der tatsache geschuldet dass
man sich aus einer sehr armen er
ausgegrenzten familie kam muss ich mir
gar nicht so viele andere möglichkeiten
geboten haben ich habe abitur gemacht
meine eltern haben beide kein abitur
gemacht nicht studiert ich hatte nicht
so planen was ich mit meinem leben
machen sollte und gleichzeitig weil die
religion so sehr meine identität dass
das irgendwie was war was ich mir
angeboten hatte wo ich das gefühl hatte
schon mit 15 jahren
ich habe diese berufung und ich hatte
dann zu vorbilder wie edith stein und da
gedacht ja genau das ist eine
intelligente gestandene frau und die
assistentin bei rusal und dann ist in
den karmel und das starke schritt und
und ja das wollte ich dann auch was
hatten sie für ein frauenbild zum
zeitpunkt ihres anträge sind in den
orten
ich habe das geglaubt was ich auch von
meinen eltern gehört habe und was auch
die kirche bis heute leer dass männer
und frauen wesentlich unterschiedlich
sind und dass männer eher die aufgabe
haben zu führen und frauen er die
aufgaben so zu dienen und sich hin zu
geben das ist zu diesen weiblichen
genius gibt von den päpsten gerne
sprechen der darin besteht dass man das
frauen irgendwie so eine seine intuition
haben menschen besser verstehen und
deswegen diese aufgabe haben auch haben
sich um kinder zu kümmern und menschen
zu kümmern und verborgenem hintergrund
zu dienen und
denn man irgendwie zuzuhören so die
haben da ein gymnasium in den 90er
jahren besucht da wurden doch bestimmt
andere werte oder andere vorstellungen
ich habe es ganz ehrlich sagen
eigentlich nicht also natürlich nicht
dieses christliche er sich unterordnen
frauenbild das habe ich in der schule
nicht erlebt aber ich habe immer für
meinen gleichaltrigen baute mädchen
erlebt in der pubertät sich nur gefragt
haben bin ich hübsch genug für die jungs
und dies ist eine frau die es irgendwie
auch als lehrerin die vorne gestanden
ist und ihr ding gemacht hat kohl war
und selbstbewusst und stark gab es auch
einmal im leben fast gar nicht ich weiß
nicht wenn ich solche frauen erlebt
hätte ob ich andere andere models gehabt
hätte ob ich anderen weg eingeschlagen
hätte aber ich hatte eigentlich eher das
gefühl meine ganz kloster gehe
emanzipierte ich mich von diesen
kindischen mädchen die sich den ganzen
tag nur damit beschäftigen wie sie
aussehen das war mir zu blöd so ich habe
er gehört ich habe gedacht ich gehe den
emanzipierten weg und bin genauso in der
falle genannt natürlich war miller und
auch sie frau höpfinger sie nicken
erleben sie die die säkulare welt auch
ähnlich schwierig also ist diese
ungleichheit zwischen den geschlechtern
gar nicht so sehr jetzt ein thema nur
der religion sondern das wird auch in
unserer säkularen raum weiter getragen
also ich glaube das ist ganz stark so
das hat mir auch die arbeit in diesen
ferien unterbeschäftigung diesem thema
ganz klar gezeigt also wir frauen das
war für mich interessant eigentlich eben
herauszufinden dass diese ideen dass wir
nicht genügend dass wir weniger wert
sind über jahrtausende transportiert
worden ist heute also es geht wirklich
immer und immer wieder darum ja als frau
genügen was muss ich spreche wie muss
ich mich verhalten wie wie muss ich mich
kleiden wie muss ich aussehen also
dieser ganze druck auch auf frauen immer
das gefühl geben eben dein körper ist
nicht genügend sein aussehen ist nicht
genug was du machst ist nicht genug und
die gesellschaft bestätigt dass ja auch
sehr oft eben frauen verdient weil wir
frauen sind 20 prozent weniger 2018 also
das ist wieso ich glaube es liegt so
tief und das ist bei uns allen zum teil
bewusst zum teil weniger bewussten die
ich hoffe halt auch dass der film
dazu beiträgt dass uns das wieder
bewusster ist nur wir auch hinschauen wo
stehen wir denn
und auch in der sexualität denke ich das
bild das von weiblicher sexualität auch
heute verbreitet wird das ebenfalls in
der werbung die objektivierung des
weiblichen körpers sei es in der
pornoindustrie die frau die absolut
alles mit sich machen lassen aber die
weibliche sexualität überhaupt nicht
lustig geht dabei immer noch verloren
wir hier noch mal zurück zur zur
geschichte frau wagner ordnen sie doch
mal für uns diese gemeinschaft ein in
diesem gesamtbild in dieser gesamten
römisch-katholischen landschaft
das werk ist eine relativ kleine
gemeinschaft ist eine neue geistliche
gemeinschaft es gibt so die großen
traditionellen ordnung benedikt ina
dominikaner franziskaner die die
jahrhunderte alt sind und es gibt so um
die mitte des 20 jahrhunderts in der
konzils nach konzil so eine ganze gruppe
von neuen geistlichen gemeinschaften die
entstanden sind in dieser zeit wo ganz
oft männer und frauen zusammenleben aber
natürlich die evangelischen
reiseversprechen armut keuschheit und
gehorsam woods und hat auch familien
dazu gehören und so und das werk gehört
in diese kategorie
neuer geistlicher gemeinschaften und ist
dieser gruppe auch insofern zuzurechnen
dass diese gruppen oft mit einer sehr
einerseits einerseits neu neuartigen
formen und einem ganz neuen auftreten
und andererseits sehr neo konservativ
sehr lehramts treu sehr papst lieben
sich geben und dadurch auch in der
kirche an gewicht erlangt haben und
einflussreiche unterstützer in rom
bekommen haben und dadurch auch sich ein
stück weit unangreifbar gemacht haben
ein teil dieser neuen erscheinung
verstehen sie darunter auch
beispielsweise dass diese gemeinschaft
in der sie eingetreten sind gemischt
geschlechtliche war ja genau das ist so
ein ein charakteristikum dass die haben
dass das eben männer und frauen da
zusammen leben und es gibt eine ganze
reihe anderer aber ich glaube das würde
zu weit führen wenn ich die dem
einzelnen aufhören dieses frauenideal
das jetzt eben beschrieben haben
was war das loyalität gehorsam
unterordnung und die vorstellung dass
wenn man einfach sich hingibt und dient
und im verborgenen kleine kleine dienste
leisteten damit sein leben verbringt
dass das ein wie glücklich macht und das
so die wahre berufung der frau wäre das
ist nun wieder etwas das nicht typisch
katholisch ist sondern das ist etwas das
wir in allen religionen sehen also diese
zuspitzung der dienenden in bezug auf
die frau das ist für viele immer noch
die das modell überhaupt sagen wir eben
in patriarchalen religionen aber auch
dort muss man unterscheiden zum beispiel
zwischen der rolle der mutter und der
rolle der ehefrau und die rolle der
nicht verheirateten frau beispielsweise
hat in der regel die mutter eine viel
stärkere macht aus die unverheiratete
frau die wie in diesem gefüge stärker
normiert ist indem sie zb dem vater
untergeordnet ist wer die mutterrolle
relativ zum teil viel macht auch
ermöglicht innerhalb des ganzen gefüge
also ich werde dort tatsächlich nochmal
unterscheiden welche art von frauen
wir müssen da gemeint aber dieses ideal
jetzt von keuschheit eben nicht nicht
eine mutterrolle zugedachten zu bekommen
nicht die rolle auch der partnerin
das ist wiederum etwas sehr spezifisch
ist im katholischen verständnis ja dass
das st und ich glaube dass auch im
katholizismus eigentlich die mächtigsten
frauen tatsächlich ordensfrauen sind und
zwar eine bestimmte kategorie nämlich
die ordensoberen großer großer
gemeinschaft oder großer größe einer
äbtissin so ungefähr dass die mächtigste
rolle die man als frau in der
katholischen kirche haben kann aber auch
wenn man eine äbtissin eines großen
benediktinerinnenkloster es irgendwo auf
der welt ist ist man immer noch männern
untergeordnet wir haben sie in ein
spieler gesehen sie haben dem papst
einen brief geschrieben sie haben
dargelegt was ihnen passiert ist haben
sie eine antwort bekommen ja fan ich
habe nicht nur beigelegt was mir
passiert ist ich habe erzählt dass ich
was mir in dieser gemeinschaft passiert
ist dass ich vergewaltigt worden bin ich
habe aber auch studien und unterlagen
zitiert er zu denen zufolge 30 prozent
aller ordensfrauen dieses schicksal
erleiden
ich habe viele zitiert von ordensfrauen
die vom priester vergewaltigt worden
die schwanger geworden sind die aus
grüßen verstoßen worden sind schwestern
die von priestern zur abtreibung
gezwungen worden sind schwestern die
verstorben sind und diese berichte legen
seit mindestens 20 jahren in rom und die
römische kurie weiß das und ich habe in
meinem brief mir erlaubt nachzufragen
was er mit diesen fällen passiert ist
überhaupt was passiert ist und die
antwort die ich bekommen habe die
mitgebrachte ich kann die gerne vorlesen
die antwort fällt so aus hiermit
bestätige ich dass ist ein privat des
staatssekretariats für das unterzeichnet
hat hiermit bestätige ich ihnen den
erhalt ihres werten schreibens vom 26
september des jahres mit dem sie dem
heiligen vater über erlebnisse in der
gemeinschaft die geistige familie das
wert berichtet haben ihre ausführungen
wurden aufmerksam zur kenntnis genommen
seine heiligkeit hat mich beauftragt
ihnen für den ausdruck ihrer mit sorge
um das wirken der kirchen unserer zeit
zu danken papst franziskus bittet sie
für ihn und seinen verantwortungsvollen
dienst als würde der universalen kirche
zu bieten er schließt auch sie und ihre
anliegen in sein gebet ein und bietet
ihnen und ihrer familie von herzen
gottes schutz und geleit für den
weiteren lebensweg
also kein angebot den fall weiter zu
verfolgen oder das thema eben anreise
aufzunehmen hatten die so etwas erwartet
weil ich gesagt ja ich habe keine großen
hoffnungen gemacht dass ich dass ich
eine echte antwort bekommen
ich habe mir sogar eigentlich erwartet
dass ich ein standardbrief bekomme mit
dem gar nicht auf meinen brief
eingegangen wird aber das hier
einerseits auf meinen brief eingegangen
wird inhaltlich in dem zumindest die
gemeinschaft abend wird in der ich war
und andere es heißt sogar nicht gar
nichts angeboten wird das hat mich schon
schockiert ja das macht wirklich dass
ich mich ich fühle mich als ob man mir
ins gesicht spuckt denken sie ihr
schreiben hat den papst persönlich
erreicht oder bleibt dass im vorzimmer
ich glaube ich glaube nicht in aller
regel passiert das nicht aber das ist
auch gar nicht der punkt dann egal wer
diesen brief öffnet irgendwo im
staatssekretariat wenn
ernsthafte dinge geht man das eigentlich
um wenn es um den bruch von kirchlichen
brechen zivilen recht geht und ich darf
nachfragen habe und ich opfer bin
erwarte ich mir eine andere art von
antwort sie haben eben eine studie
zitiert die sie heran gezogen haben um
darzulegen wie häufig dass missbräuche
in orten vorkommen missbräuche an frauen
an ordensschwestern vorkommen es gab
gestern einen artikel der offengelegt
hat das natürlich auch in der schweiz
danach gefragt wurde und das fachgremium
für sexuelle übergriffe der
schweizerischen bischofskonferenz hat
dazu stellung genommen hat gesagt in der
schweiz sei kein einziger fall bekannt
nicht dass eine ordensfrau von einem
priester sexuell missbraucht worden sei
erstaunt sie das das macht mich müde
weil ich mir denke ja das ist so das
übliche in der kirche dass man sagt ja
wenn verantwortliche können keine fälle
also gibt es keine müssen wir nichts tun
das ist so logisch dass verantwortliche
keine fälle kennen und das heißt
überhaupt nicht dass es keine gibt
sondern wenn ich an einer
verantwortlichen position bin und ich
das erste mal erfahren dass es solche
studien gibt das was euch jetzt ein gibt
und weil ich nicht glaube dass sie das
bis jetzt nicht wissen
dann wäre eigentlich die aufgabe zu
sagen ja wir forschen nach denn die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auch bei uns
fälle gibt es relativ hoch und wenn wenn
wir von nichts wissen dann liegt das
daran dass die opfer sich nicht trauen
zu sprechen oder nicht sprechen können
frauen haben so eine große hürde um über
sexuelle gewalt zu sprechen
und wenn man schwestern im kloster ist
ist die hütte nochmals so viel gehör
dass die allermeisten überhaupt niemals
mit irgend jemandem darüber sprechen und
die erste aufgabe von verantwortlichen
wäre diese schwelle niedriger zu machen
und den den opfern die sehr
wahrscheinlich gibt hilfe anzubieten
frau höpflinger dieses gremium um das
innerkirchlich dieser übergriffe
gemeldet werden können wurde 2002
eingerichtet denken sie damit es genug
getan
nein auf jeden fall nicht also da muss
wirklich etwas getan werden solche fälle
müssen untersucht werden und eben ich
finde auch die antwort genau wie sie
gesagt haben
ehrlich gesagt mit eigentlich dass man
sagt ja es gibt es nicht weil wir nichts
davon wissen
also da müsste man sehr viel machen also
einerseits nach sich den frauen den mut
machen darüber zu sprechen
und dafür ist dieser film genial also
und auch ihr erfahrungsbericht aber
andererseits doch auch von
institutioneller seite vielleicht doch
mal ein bisschen schritte einleiten noch
auf jeden fall
der film zeigt diese fünf geschichten
und ich sage jetzt mal etwas provokativ
es sind doch außergewöhnliche
geschichten es sind nicht jede jüdin
wächst im ultraorthodoxen video auf das
ultra orthodoxe mio ist eine minderheit
innerhalb der jüdischen
religionsgemeinschaft schlechthin
nicht jede katholikin trettin einen
orden ein
es sind doch außergewöhnliche fälle also
für mich ja natürlich in das fälle die
vielleicht zum teil auch
extremsituationen sind aber ich glaube
die ganze erfahrung als frau ist auch
auswärts vorgesprochen habe neben der
kirche getrauen sich frauen nicht zu
über sexuelle gewalt zu sprechen wenn
man die zahlen anschaut also 85 prozent
der vergewaltigungs fälle in der schweiz
in deutschland in europa werden nicht
angezeigt das heißt die die schwelle für
alle frauen und auch männer darüber zu
sprechen aus dieser charme und diesem
gefühl von ich bin schon ich habe was
falsch gemacht was er die gesellschaft
dann auch wieder widerspiegelt weil von
diesen 85 prozent der fälle die nicht
angezeigt also die 15 werden angezeigt
davon gibt es sieben bis zehn prozent
der täter werden nur verurteilt und da
geht es wieder genau darum aber was hast
du angezogen wie hast du dich verhalten
wahrscheinlich warst du betrunken aus
die mit schotter frau dieses gefühl von
ja du hast was gemacht dein körper ist
ebenso dass er bei den männern was
auslösen dann bist du verantwortlich
dafür das ist so überall und das hat
überhaupt nichts mit einer bestimmten
religionsgemeinschaft zu tun
und wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel
unterdrückung der weiblichen sexualität
schauen also genitalverstümmelung wo man
kann sagen ist einer der extremen
physischen arten das sind 200 millionen
frauen und mädchen das ist nicht kleiner
in der haid oder in indien wo die frauen
absolut als minderwertig angeschaut sind
das ist eine halbe milliarde frauen
das ist nicht so ist es nicht so eine
kleine nebensache sondern das betriebs
uns allen dass frauen die größere
verantwortung tragen damit sie
körperlich integer bleiben hängt
natürlich auch ganz stark damit zusammen
dass die sexualität viel stärker und der
frau festgemacht wird die ehre der
familie die rein dass die reinheit
vorstellungen
woher kommt das überhaupt in den
religionen das reinheit unversehrtheit
und sexualität derart stark an der frau
und nicht zumindest gleichwertigen
beiden geschlechtern fest gemacht werden
also wieder das ist bei patriarchalen
religion und dort mich vorhin gesagt
habe ist die religion ist ausgerichtet
auf den mann und die frau ist ein
bisschen böse gesagt in diesem kontext
der besitz des mannes und dann ist klar
dass der besitz reguliert wird aber ich
über spitze jetzt mit absicht ein
bisschen um es deutlich zu machen
also es gibt natürlich auch regulierung
des ortes man das ganz klar aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass die die frau wird
insofern muss ich stärker normieren um
weil es aus dem man ausgerichtet ist wie
um ihm seine welt gerecht fertig zu
werden
sie haben mir das ganz starken erlebt
dass sozusagen jeder annäherung zwischen
den geschlechtern gleich an der frau
festgemacht wird
es war in meinem fall richtig krass ich
hab das ich habe das lange nicht
verstanden weil ich irgendwie schon sehr
naiv da reingegangen bin und gedacht hat
ja ich habe an dieses ideal gewerblicher
aber lange nicht verstanden was damit
kommt und dieser moment wo man mit wenn
wir das unterkleid gegeben hat und
gesagt betragen das ist und ich landete
www instinktiv angefangen habe mich zu
schämen und dann wöchentliche gespräche
mit meiner oberen die immer gesagt
schwester doris du darfst nicht so
schauen du musst irgendwie anders
schauen und du sollst nicht so stehen
sondern so und nicht so laut reden aber
auch nicht zu leise reden und ich habe
gar nicht mehr gewusst wie ich hab ja
ich bin halt da was soll ich mich dann
verhalten was ist dann richtig und ich
war mir immer keiner schuld bewusst und
er später durch falsch verstanden dass
hinter jeder solche anweisung
ein mitbruder gestanden war der gesang
die schwester doris ist ein problem für
mich und nicht verstanden hat dass er
das problem ist wenn er sich zu mir
hingezogen fühlt und damit nicht umgehen
kann und stattdessen ist das von mir
gelandet und hat mich ein wirklich in
die verzweiflung getrieben weil ich gar
nicht mehr gewusst habe was ich was ich
noch tun soll bis zu dem moment wo ich
meine oberen sagt der pater burkhard
schlecht mehr und sie mich an schreit
und sagt du wirst zur gefahr für ihn
anstatt ihm zu sagen warum steigen sie
das messer durch es nach lassen sie in
ruhe lassen die unsere ich glaube ich
habe hatte ich war ich war
verantwortlich aber ich konnte ja auch
nicht so einer situation ändern so und
dass das einfach so knallhart verkannt
worden ist und ich in dieser
hilflosigkeit in dieser situation allein
gelassen worden war wirklich extrem und
ich habe viel zu spät erst dann gemerkt
dass ich in der vater setzte als sie
dann aus der gemeinschaft ausgetreten
sind haben sie dann eine einen rasanten
sozusagen ein raser und das leben
aufgenommen sie wurden sie haben dann
geheiratet sie wurden mutter sie haben
an diesem filmprojekt mit gemacht sie
haben ein studium absolvieren sie haben
ihre doktorarbeit abgegeben
erinnern sie sich wie die rückkehr in
die gesellschaft verliehen
im nachhinein ist schnell gegangen für
mich hat sich das langsam an gefühlt
weil ich so viel neu lernen musste und
so viel neu anfangen musste oder so viel
mich normal kleiden war sehr sehr
schwierigen hat sehr lange gedauert bis
ich mich getraut habe bis ich nicht mehr
mich nicht mehr schuldig gefühlt hat er
wenig hosen getragen habe oder so das
hat das hat lange gedauert und zugleich
war jeder schritt den ich gegangen bin
ein unglaublich gutes gefühl und ein ich
hab so dass das gefühl dass ich auch
jetzt in meinem alltag wenn ich nämlich
eis essen gehen oder wenn ich mir ein
schönes kleid kaufen oder wenn ich in
die oper gehe anand heute machen das
ganze zeit verständlich und ich hatte
mir das gefühl wie außergewöhnlich wie
besonderes was was für ein geschenk
wie hat die geschichte denn ihre
religiosität geprägt können sie noch
festhalten an den
glaubens ansichten und lehrmeinungen der
der römisch katholischen kirche
nein nein das kann ich das kann ich
nicht und trotzdem würde ich nicht sagen
dass ich meinen glauben verloren habe
und ich glaube das verdanke ich meinem
theologiestudium
ich habe ja in dem moment wo ich
ausgetreten bin hatte ich schon
theologisch angefangen zu studieren hat
der mine theologie studium beendet und
jetzt in philosophie promoviert und es
ist wirklich studium war unglaublich
wichtig für mich um zu verstehen warum
diese ideologie in der wir in der
gemeinschaft gerät haben nicht haltbar
ist warum die bibel das gar nicht
hergibt warum das rational nicht
vertretbar ist und gleichzeitig aber
auch die sachen in meiner region die mir
wichtig mit denen ich aufgewachsen bin
als kleines kind die mein ganzes leben
geprägt haben mir die sachen zu retten
wo ich sage dies sind trotzdem schön und
dass er trotzdem so einstellen wird und
da bin ich trotzdem zu hause und das
kann ich auch rational verantwortet tun
wie unterschiedlich männliche und
weibliche sexualität bewertet werden
thematisiert der film auch wir haben
drei szenen ausgewählt die berühren aber
auch irritieren
ich habe auf dem tahrir platz war am
donnerstag 5
[Musik]
ein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo
dapd
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie sagt es hat sei es so eine
selbstverständlichkeit lasst es uns alle
akzeptieren dass wir das alle genießen
aber die realität ist eben eine andere
für männer ist die sexualität positiv
setzt für frauen ist sie oftmals negativ
besetzt wie haben sie das in den
dreharbeiten erlebt wenn sie mit männern
zusammen kamen wir haben die auf das
reagiert also bei den dreharbeiten was
interessant weil zum beispiel eben das
witzig aus indien oder lehrer hussein
aus somalia london sie arbeiten auch
ganz stark mit männern zusammen
also das war auch toll zu sehen dass
diese arbeit dieses umdenken eben
eigentlich wirklich mit männern
gemeinsam gemacht werden muss damit sich
wirklich etwas bewegt oder für mich was
auch toll zu sehen die partner den
tollen partner der protagonistin die
väter auch die hinter dem stehen
natürlich nicht überall also worauf
feldmann ihre familie hat sie verstoßen
aber die tigers in indien oder
lederhosen auch ihr vater oder in japan
bei der japanischen künstlerin ist es
der vater der zum gerichtsprozess kommt
und deshalb ich stehe hinter dem was
meine tochter sagt und macht auch wenn
sie zu hause über sexualität gesprochen
hatten vorher aber im die mutter die
schämt sich also es war eigentlich
wirklich toll zu erleben dass von einer
gewissen art von männern die vielleicht
auch ganz lange geschwiegen haben weil
das eben als nicht diese art von
männlichkeit verstanden wird die bei uns
immer gesagt wird das ist ein richtiger
mann
dass die jetzt anfangen farbe zu
bekennen sein nein ich möchte mit frauen
ich möchte frauen unterstützen ich
möchte mit frauen zusammenarbeiten
ich möchte eine gleichberechtigte
partnerschaft dass es war auch total
schön für mich zu erleben dass das eben
in ganz vielen ländern jetzt auch
passieren
freilich könnten sie sich auch
vorstellen dass wenn sie ideen kommen
eines partnerschaftlichen verständnisses
beispielsweise dass das in gewissen
ländern auch aber als ein
imperialistischer vorstoß sozusagen
verstanden werden konnte und sagt jetzt
kommen die westler wieder und sagen wir
es doch eigentlich richtig wer und wie
das verhältnis zwischen den
geschlechtern verlaufen sollte und was
richtige sexualität ist und wo sie
legitim ist
das hatten wir doch alles schon mal vor
allem vor 200 jahren das ist tatsächlich
ein großes problem gerade bei der
genitalverstümmelung also der weiblichen
genitalverstümmelung dass diese debatten
im aufkommen und schon der begriff wird
debattiert also soll man
genitalverstümmelung ich bin sehr für
diesen begriff alles ist eine
verstümmelung aber selbstverständlich
könnte das auch auf ihn pianistisch
angesehen werden so die idee der westen
sagt jetzt wieder das ist eine
verstümmelung keine tradition und dass
es quasi wie sogar den fremdschaden
könnte in der man nur schon diesen
begriff verwendet statt hier vorsichtig
gehört zu sein
aber das sind der banken ich denke man
muss die reflektieren sie sind extrem
wichtig aber selbstverständlich ist die
welt unterdessen globalisiert und es
geht nicht mehr nur mit diesen lokalen
ideen von tradition sondern es gibt
diesen austausch und mit dem müssen wir
leben von beiden seiten also die mit
migration hat ja die thematik auch noch
mal neu angefacht in dem das ich weiß
nicht wie viele tausend fälle von
genitalverstümmelung bei frauen in
europäischen ländern dokumentiert werden
also es ist nicht mehr so dass wir
einfach sagen können das ist ein problem
dass wir auf einen anderen kontinent
verlagern
nein überhaupt nicht ich glaube das ist
eben auch wichtigen unseren
gesellschaften hinzuschauen
eben wie gehen wir mit dem um was das
bis jetzt haben wir ja auch gesagt ja
das sind traditionen die muss man
respektieren um ehrenmorde wurden auch
in der schweiz ganz lange weniger hart
ihre morde verurteilt als ein anderer
morgen also das ist ein auch ein
falsches kulturverständnis und
degerfelden und sagt auch im filmjahr
zum beispiel weil sie in dieser
jüdischen gemeinschaft mitten in new
york gelebt hat und das familienrecht
aber dieser gemeinschaft angewandt wurde
hatte sie als frau viel weniger recht
sie konnte sich nicht scheiden lassen
sie hatte keinen anspruch auf das kind
und und und also da glaube ich auch ist
es wichtig dass wir auch hinschauen und
was für mich auch so toll war bei diesen
frauen auch aus einer anderen kultur zu
sehen eben es ist nicht ein film ich
gehe hin und erzähle was wichtig ist und
wie es richtig gemacht wird sondern das
sind frauen aus diesen kulturen aus
diesen ländern sagen es reicht wir
wollen gleichberechtigung wir wollen als
gleichwertige respektvolle wesen auch
mit einer eigenen selbstbestimmte
sexualität angeschaut
aber es gab auch eine begegnung das
haben wir jetzt nicht gesehen mit einem
hindu priester der sagt homosexualität
gehört nicht zu unserer kultur übrigen
sagen dass afrikanische bischöfe ganz
genauso
in afrika gibt es keine homosexualität
deswegen gibt es auch keinen missbrauch
beim bestimmte schiffe sagt missbraucht
wird nur durch homosexuelle begangen und
deswegen das ist ein afrika kein thema
also ich glaube diese diese debatte
westliche kulturen andere kulturen ist
wie eine alibi debatte dann auch bei uns
im westen waren menschenrechte ganz
kleine nicht teil der kultur
wir haben eine entwicklung durchgemacht
und haben das erkannt und wenn wenn die
menschen deren rechte beschnitten werden
ich glaube erst wenn die wirklich selber
sagen ich will das so glaube ich dass
was den ihre kultur ist aber ganz oft
sind es die menschen in bestimmten
ländern die andere unterdrücken wollen
und dazu den begriff kultur oder
religion benutzen und die sich das nicht
nehmen lassen wollen und deswegen ihre
kultur über die menschenrechte stellen
aber das kann ist niemandes beckett ihm
gehen wir mal zu der fragestellung nach
lösungen zu suchen wir haben eben schon
mal kurz das angesprochen vielleicht
gibt es einen weiteren film der dann
vielleicht die positiven zitate in den
inschriften als als grundlage nimmt aber
was ist denn der gewinn der männer wenn
sie die macht abgeben die muss man
überzeugen
ich glaube dass das was es ist sicher
schwierig ich meine wir erleben jeden
tag die schwierigkeiten aber ich glaube
ganz ehrlich dass männer nur gewinnen
können
es gibt eine szene im film wenn wohl was
sagt er ganz viele frauen können sechs
nicht genießen weil sie sich mit ihrem
körper nicht wohl fühlen und ich komme
wie viel schöner ist das auch für ein
mann mit einer frau zu schlafen die
ihren körper liebt und die das einfach
voll genießen kann
männer sollten das wollen ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass man alles nicht
wollen beginnt es schon bei der
schwierigkeit überhaupt darüber zu
sprechen wir halten uns hier ja schon
für sehr aufgeklärt und und tut man das
so und wir haben schnell den blick auf
andere kultur dass wir sagen
bei der entspricht man wirklich gewollt
als teil der kulturellen identität nicht
so offen über diese dinge haben sie das
so erlebt den dreharbeiten das ist
sicher so dass andere kultur noch viel
eine größere hemmschwelle haben oder der
gesellschafts druck noch viel stärker
ist aber ich glaube auch bei uns also
wenn lehrer hussein sagt eben der chor
der frauen einen orgasmus vorzutäuschen
da geht durch die ganze welt weil heißt
das ja eigentlich auch als frauen trauen
wir uns nicht zu sagen was wir möchten
oder was unser bedürfnis ist oder es
wird bei kleinen mädchen schon gesagt
hast dich da unten nicht an also schon
keine worte dafür daneben den eigenen
körper entdecken lieben
ich glaube auch dieser ganze druck auf
mädchen und frauen eben das aussehen
dass das genügen müssen
das hat so viel damit zu tun dass auch
die eigene sexualität nicht ja nicht
lustvoll gelebt werden darf und sei es
jetzt in japan sei es in irgendwann sei
es aber auch bei uns was frauen wirklich
sich nicht getrauen zu sagen was ja ich
möchten und das oft auch nicht gelernt
haben
sie hat mir bevor sie diesen film
gemacht haben auch einen film über
pornographie gemacht und sie haben in
diesem film hier auch zum beginn bilder
verwendet die aus der werbung kommen die
überhaupt nicht irgendwie ein positives
bild der frau zeichnen das spielt aber
religion gar keine rolle
ich habe für mich ist eigentlich der
blick darauf so früher eben durch die
religion und gesellschaft gehörten die
frauen sich verhüllen jetzt ist
eigentlich das wichtigste frauen
enthüllen sich lassen alles mit sich
machen sind aber wieder objekt und nicht
subjekt also ich habe auch nur für eine
klitoris gemacht und wenn man jetzt
mainstream pornos anschaute
das wichtigste wäre ja eigentlich für
die frau für eine befriedigende für
einen orgasmus 70 prozent der frauen
haben nur ein orgasmus über die klitoris
wer die klitoris sie existiert nicht in
den mainstream pornos oder etwas war er
vor zwei wochen in der schweiz ist
rausgekommen das neue schulbücher in die
schule gekommen sind kann die klitoris
wieder fehlt und dann herausgestellt
jahre sind fundamentalistisch
fundamental rallye
böse katholische kreise die haben jetzt
schulbücher ausgegeben was eben die
klitoris das heißt wieder die frau wird
auf das gebären auf die mutterrolle auf
das kinder kommen reduziert aber die
looks die weibliche lust irgendwie
klitoris dass sich auch wohlfühlen
das ist wieder kein ding wo muss dieses
thema diskutiert oder debattiert werden
in der schule in öffentlichen
institutionen oder ihrer ansicht nach
eher im privaten raum also ich glaube an
allen orten was fängt wirklich beim
umgang mit mädchen und jungs an wenn man
zu hause wie man die kinder erzieht wie
man ihnen eben ein beibringen mit ihrem
körper ihr körpergefühl von nein sagen
also das eben zum beispiel jemand möchte
sie küssen und sie sagen nein und hast
du musst diese person küste schon dieses
gefühl von ich darf nicht über meinen
körper entscheiden oder eben da unten
etwas mädchen auch lernen ihren körper
zu entdecken das man sind nicht
unterbindet und dann die schule die
offen mit diesem thema umgeht die
gesellschaft leben die bilder jetzt im
internet pornografie ist überall das wir
auch dahin schon ja wollen wir diese
firma so wollen wir dass unsere
jugendlichen bilden damit so einen
rollenverständnis wieder aufwecken
also ich glaube es ist wirklich überall
und ich finde das auch so toll
bei den fünf frauen im film dass sie
wirklich all diese aspekte ansprechen
und dass die für euch alle auch ganz
wichtig waren überall hinzuschauen und
veränderung anzustoßen und auch soja
dass er glaubt dass sich etwas verändern
kann und auch diese ausstrahlung hatten
wirklich sein vorbild charakter das hat
mir unglaublich viel mut auch gegeben
und zuversicht dass auch etwa eine
veränderung wirklich jetzt möglich ist
mir ist noch aufgefallen es gibt einen
religion oder in den kulturen eigentlich
so zwei grundsätzliche sichtweise
nämlich der mann ist in gefahr durch die
frau nämlich durch die verführung
also muss er sie kontrollieren oder aber
die frau ist in gefahr und deshalb muss
sie geschützt werden
in beiden fällen ist offenbar sexualität
aber nicht denkbar ohne dass es
gefährlich ist also dieses entspannte
was wir fordern
ich lasse mich auch ein stück weit eine
illusion aus und das entspannte eine
illusion
das dass wir überhaupt entspannt mit
sexualität umgehen können weil dieses
gefahrenpotenzial ja offenbar derart
groß ist die frage ist woher kommt das
gefahrenpotenzial und ich würde es so
erklären dass sexualität ist natürlich
was rational alles aber auch hochgradig
was ihr rationales also ein orgasmus ist
sehr unkontrollierbar und das dann
religionen das in die kontrolle über
führen wollen liegt irgendwie auf der
hand durch regulierungen aber ich denke
es ist schon möglich bin vielleicht ein
bisschen optimistisch jetzt aus der
kreis hier aber dass zum beispiel sein
film gezeigt wird dass eine sternstunde
sendung darüber gemacht wenn zeigt doch
als baum wird sich etwas und ich finde
auch man muss überall darüber reden
ich finde auch die kategorie privat und
öffentlich ein bisschen heikel weil es
automatisch dann wieder heißt die frau
ist das private man das öffentliche
internet würde ich diese kategorien gar
nicht mehr setzen sondern tatsächlich
also die zustimmen die solche themen
müssen überall behandelt werden ob sie
gefährlich sind oder nicht
das entscheiden am ende die leute die
darüber reden
frau wagner haben sie auch diese
hoffnung für die römisch katholische
kirche die haben jetzt von veränderung
gehört wir haben die reaktionen der
jungen männer gesehen in london für die
veränderung schlagartig realität wie
dass sie sich anders zu gewissen dingen
stellen
wie sehen sie das finden ihre kirche ich
glaube man muss ganz klar können
zwischen normalen menschen noch mal
einen katholiken und der kirchenführung
in rom
und ich glaube für normale katholiken
habe ich ganz viel hoffnung da hat sich
auch schon so wahnsinnig viel verändert
also ich hab mir an drei verschiedenen
fakultäten katholische theologie
studiert und da ist es ganz normal unter
studenten dass die dass die
partnerschaften eingehen dass sie sex
haben bevor sie heiraten dass sie kinder
haben bevor er sie heiraten dass man da
ist dass das homosexuelle
partnerschaften gibt dass sie dass
verhütung keine sünde ist das ist da
überhaupt gar kein thema mehr
aber es ist ein ganz großes thema für
einige bischöfe und kardinäle in rom und
bischöfe auf dem auf bischof sitzen
weltweit die sich ganz schwer damit tun
darüber zu sprechen
die eine ganz absurde sexualmoral
vertreten und ich glaube auch nicht dass
ich das dann wird zum beispiel ist
selbstbefriedigung eine schwere sünde
nach wie vor und ich kann keinen bischof
weltweit dass ich damit konträr
ausgesprochen hätte oder gesagt hätten
das können wir heute so nicht mehr
vertreten das macht könnte macht auch
biologisch übrigens keinen sinn sondern
das ist die offizielle wäre und ich habe
nicht viel hoffnung dass sich das noch
ändert obschon es ganz viele und ganz
weite frauenkreise auch gibt in der
römisch katholischen kirche die diese
engen und den wandel ja schon seit
jahrzehnten debattieren ja das ist es
gibt so viele menschen die wahnsinnig
frustriert sind mit der grieche weil die
seit jahrzehnten investieren dass das
einfach die bischöfe zur vernunft kommen
und das funktioniert deswegen nicht weil
die kirche aufgebaut ist als absolute
monarchie
das heißt da geht alles von oben nach
unten und es ist alles instrument
transparent und man kann zur vernünftige
argumente haben man kann so schlimme
leidensgeschichten haben man kann 90
prozent des kirchenvolks hinter sich
haben und trotzdem bringt man nicht
durch und an dieser struktur wird sich
nichts ändern außer der papst selber
schafft sie ab und das ist ja
unverständlich und deswegen fürchte ich
dass das wir im winter auf einen
zusammenbruch rechtlichen struktur hin
steuern oder das einfach oder dass es
sich einfach abspaltet und die menschen
die diese extreme sichtweise vertreten
und diese so und so bewahren wollen
einfach immer bedeutungsloser werden
immer weniger werden und das große gong
die große menge der normalen katholiken
an anderen weg geht und sich unabhängig
macht von dieser institution
wir sind schon fast am schluss barbara
müller sie haben jetzt diesen film in
der schweiz in europa auch gezeigt wer
läuft jetzt gerade planen sie ihn auch
in asien in afrika zu zeigen ja
unbedingt
es ist auch sehr ein großer wunsch der
protagonistinnen dass er wirklich in der
ganzen welt gezeigt wird wir müssen
überlegen wie wir den indien zeigen
können
in afrikanischen ländern das ist auch
ganz wichtig dass es war wirklich ja ich
glaube er kann etwas bewegen
die frauen sind unglaublich für mich zu
vorbildern geworden ich glaube wir
können für ganz viele frauen und auch
männer zuvor bilder werden wie sie die
welt verändern
du hast vorhin gesagt haben du bist
positiver gestimmt dass ich glaube also
wenn du nach dem was ich auch mit diesem
film erlebt habe es ist ein
unglaublicher wandel in gange und wir
können jetzt wirklich etwas verändern
und das tiefgreifend ist und bleiben
auch ist ein wunderbares schlusswort ich
bedanke mich bei ihnen allen war pamela
doris wagner frau springer
vielen dank dass sie daran um danke
nächste woche geht es in der sternstunde
religion um die frage wie die begegnung
zwischen opfer und täter von gewalt
verbrechen heilsam sein kann jetzt
gleich lehrt uns in der sternstunde
philosophie der psychologe steven pinker
dass die welt viel besser ist als viele
von uns glauben bleiben sie dran
[Musik]